[музика]
Привіт друзі і дорослі і малеча з вами
пані Ліда і ведмедик бо привіт
Ну що ж минулого разу ми з вами вивчили
літеру з і звук з а сьогодні нам час
переходити до наступної літери але ця
літера дуже сором'язлива знаєте чому
вона ніколи не стоїть на початку слова і
її потрібно шукати у словах Вона може
бути в кінці чи у середині і ніколи на
початку уявляєте
Отже Подивіться як виглядає ця літера и
на що вона схожа ведмедику Тобі на що
схожа літера и мені ну якісь паркончик
і мені на парканчик А вам друзі що
нагадує літера и
давайте з вами викладемо її зараз з
олівців Подивіться будь ласка
для цього нам потрібно скільки олівчик
Як ви думаєте а ми порахуємо викладемо і
порахуємо ось один олівчик
потім другий олівчик
і ще третій олівчик Ось і вийшла в нас
літера и
це
звук голосний и ми можемо його
проспівати вимовити без перешкод Давайте
спробуємо
и-и
молодці а зараз
ми з вами використовуючи голосний и
[музика]
приголосні які ми вже з вами вивчили
спробуємо прочитати склади ось наприклад
б
на переду і и разом ведмедику прочитаємо
би
Молодці супер тепер змінюючи приголосний
читаємо наступний склад
ваша черга малята
ведмедику
Ви
молодці правильно гарно ви запам'ятали
літери так тепер
наступний склад ведмедику
де
молодці
гаразд і останній ще один склад який у
вас вийде пам'ятаєте цю літеру як вона
називається
ж і звук Ж на жучка подібна вірно
покладемо її попереду і вийде в нас
склад
ж Ого молодець ведмедик ти прочитав усі
склади супер добре а зараз послухайте
будь ласка пісеньку про літеру и и из
буквами на Т у словах мерщій знайди
шишка
Боровик ялина листя гілочки
мавина Ого як багато літер и у цій
пісеньці
Давайте ми її з вами розлучимо
гаразд
Отже ти із буквами на Т повторіть
у словах мерщій знайди мерщій тобто
швидше знайди її у словах
у словах мерщій знайди
шишка
Боровик Боровик друзі це такий гриб
правда ведмедику Ти бачив у лісі
боровики бачу Я їх люблю
шишка Боровик ялина
листя гілочки малина
А тепер цю пісеньку разом
із буквами на Т у словах мерщій знайди
шишка Боровик ялина листя гілочки
Нумо заспіваймо разом
із буквами на Т у словах мерщій знайди
шишка Боровик ялина листя гілочки малина
супер молодці друзі ведмедику А ти хочеш
заспівати цю пісеньку
здається я вже вивчив слова ну
Заспівай будь ласка діткам
із буквами ноти у словах мовчить знайди
Шишко буровик ялина листя гілочки
малина Ого малинка ти любиш малинку
ведмедику любить любить маленьку звісно
ведмедиків всім полюбляють малинку
Ну що ж ми величезні молодці розручили з
вами пісеньку А зараз приготуйтесь
побавимось з вами у гру зараз на екрані
будуть слова і вам потрібно
віднайти у цих словах літеру И але не
шукайте її на початку слова тому що вона
дуже сором'язлива пам'ятаєте Вона стоїть
десь у середині Шукайте і будьте уважні
Приготуйте долоньки
Нумо починаємо
кит
ласкаємо молодці
тигр
є там літера молодці вода
килим
[музика]
так аж дві літери И ми двічі можемо
плеснути у долоні лимон
[музика]
супер молодці плескаємо мило
є дрова
немає не плескаємо у долоні і останнє
слово
лицар і ми знову плескаємо у долоні
супер молодці Вам вдалося А зараз нашу
улюблену рубрика з ведмежатком наші
загадки ось послухайте про кого Вони
будуть цього разу
у норі хатинку має хліб сирочок полюбляє
по підлозі тишком-нишком бігає сіренько
то така маленька і сіренька бігає по
підлозі
мишка правильно молодці чи є у слові
мишка літера і звук и
є Звісно що є Ви чуєте як ми його
вимовляємо Це голосний звук адже ми
можемо його проспівати
вірно А скажіть будь ласка що полюбляють
їсти мишки ведмедику що люблять їсти
мишки
[музика]
Я щось не знаю мишки друзі люблять їсти
сир і у слові сир також є літера і звук
и
і зараз остання загадка але будьте дуже
уважні відгадку Ви точно знаєте
дуже я потрібна всім і дорослим і малим
всіх я розуму учу а сама завжди мовчу що
це Як ви думаєте
ведмедику ти знаєш що це ні І я не
здогадався
сама мовчить всіх навчаю розуму тож це
така Ой здається я знаю Здається це
можливо це книга вірно ведмедику ти
Розумник це книга Друзі Ну що ж сьогодні
ми з вами вивчили
сором'язливу літеру И вивчили пісеньку
про неї і
склали і навчилися читати склади
А нам з вами час прощатись ведмедику
будемо прощати з дітками Ну все добре До
нових зустрічей так-так до нових
зустрічей друзі па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами юстинка і Пані Настя
ми сьогодні з вами заспіваємо пісеньку А
ця пісня Буде про пору року яка в нас
зараз є весна та зараз весна і ми з вами
заспіваємо пісеньку про весну щоб у нас
була гарна погода тепле сонечко І ще щоб
були дощики бо якщо в нас будуть дощі то
нас потім будуть смачні різні фрукти
овочі та і гарненькі зелені рослинки так
правильно давайте з вами вивчимо рухи
які ми будемо робити Нам потрібно буде
створити музику за допомогою нашого тіла
Давайте ми з вами будь ласка ти
поколінька так ми будемо плескати по
колінках бачите якщо ми плескаємо
полінках спробуйте то в нас виходить ось
такий звук як дощик і ми з вами будемо
робити наче таку музику
для пісеньки ми будемо робити її Ось так
будемо плескати собі раз іншу ручку 2 3
поколінці і потім по іншій раз і почище
добре ми плескаємо по одній Колінці Три
рази ще раз раз два три потім по іншій
раз і раз Окей добре Давайте спробуємо
повторити цей рух трошечки швидше раз
два три раз два Окей і ми будемо робити
ці рухи цілу пісню будуть змінюватись
тільки слова давайте з вами почнемо
Будемо починати з таких слів
зібрались усі
гукати весну Давайте спробуємо
гукати весну
за далеких гір і тепер приспів ой прийди
весна ой прийди красна Давайте спробуємо
з рухами ой прийди весна ой прийди
красна Ну і тепер наступні слова
Принеси до нас
тепле літечко Давайте спробуємо з рухами
тепле літечко і коли в нас будуть ці
слова в кінці робимо ось так
у-у наші кличемо весну Окей Давайте
спробуємо разом з початку І до того
моменту як ми вивчили зібрали всю сіль
гукати весну
зібрались усі
за далеких гір і приспів ой прийди весна
ой прийди красна
Принеси до нас
тепле літечко
вуж Чудово Ну а тепер коли прийде до нас
весна ми мусимо в неї щось попросити щоб
вона щось з собою принесла будемо
просити в неї щоб вона принесла до нас
тепла так тепла будуть такі слова
Принеси до нас
теплій душі
теплій дощі
шовкову траву Давайте спробуємо зробити
це з рухами
Принеси до нас
теплій дощі
шовкову траву Ну і приспів ой прийди
весна ой прийди красна
Принеси до нас
тепле літечко
вух Чудово Ну і тепер Давайте спробуємо
Повторити все від початку і до кінця
якщо ви забуваєте слова Це не страшно
головне повторюєте ось ці рухи Окей
приготувалися приготували ручки всі
готові чудово
поїхали
зібрались усіх
гукати весну
гукати весною
задалекий гір ой прийди весна ой прийди
к нам
Принеси до нас
тепле літечко
вуж і далі
Принеси до нас
тепліє дощі
теплій дощі
шовкову траву і приспів ой прийди весна
ой прийди красна
Принеси до нас
тепле літечко
гу- чудово закликали весну Молодці дуже
гарно Ну тепер Настав час прощатися
па-па
[музика]